question is
hey lex i was curious how you pick
people
to come on to the podcast
i think this process is actually quite
difficult and it evolved
over time so let me mention a few
factors
i think first and foremost
it's important that a a person is
really passionate about what they do and
that passion can take all kinds of
different forms
i know i sometimes or all the time
completely lack emotion
in my face but i
truly am passionate about the things i
do and so
that passion can express itself in
different ways and so coupled with that
passion i look for people who are
sort of not only passionate but they
appreciate enjoy
are drawn to the long-form conversation
format as a way to express that passion
which is not everybody some people love
to express
their passion their interest their
expertise
their ideas in written form maybe that's
more kind of edited over several passes
of editing
versus a conversation format especially
long-form conversation where there's
very little editing
in addition to that i'm also try
to make sure the person actually wants
to come on to this particular podcast
you know there's so many amazing
podcasts out there and
it's also just surprising to see how
much better they are
than me at talking conversations
explaining stuff
it's humbling it's also inspiring
because it pushes me to kind of
improve seeing what's possible so
i don't know if people don't actually
listen to this particular podcast or at
least have listened a little bit
and are not drawn to the particular
flavor of weirdness that is me like some
kid who wears a suit all the time and
like
mumbles speaks slowly asks these weird
questions i mean
if if they're not drawn to whatever the
hell that weird mystery
is of this particular human then there's
no reason
to to talk if they're drawn i think
there's a possibility of something
magical happening
me with my weirdness and them with their
weirdness kind of colliding in
interesting ways that
create something new that both of us are
surprised by
and on that topic more and more i'm
looking for people that are
different than me and that means the
full spectrum
of diversity so it could be different
backgrounds
different world views different
personalities
like you can tell there'll be a clash of
flavors
it's like chocolate and salt
but it can also turn out to be uh like a
pineapple pizza
that actually some people love but i
don't understand
it doesn't even it doesn't make any
sense why
it doesn't make any sense so it could be
you know taking that risk
of embracing that clash and the
chemistry can sometimes
result in a pineapple pizza so uh
there's a cost to that risk but i
i seek it out more because i think
that's the possibility of some
magical experience of a magical
conversation
and on that topic i should mention
there's this kind of idea of platforming
which is
i've been fortunate enough to have sort
of
enough listeners and viewers that the
question of platforming even comes up
meaning if you have this kind of
guest with these kind of controversial
viewpoints
why give them a platform that's
further spreads their viewpoints and
i understand i empathize with this kind
of
view but i don't like it because
to me if i'm successful now that's the
problem
i'm not very good at this thing
especially in challenging conversations
so
but if i'm successful that the
tension and world views the tension and
personalities
the clash will create
wisdom so i really want to talk to
very challenging people i want to have
really difficult conversations
and that means talking to people that
are at the outskirts of society i think
it's something that
i'm thinking about a lot
it's important to say that i'm not
afraid of being canceled
i do think i'm afraid or perhaps the
better word is
concerned about doing a terrible job
on a important difficult conversation
where as a result of me doing a terrible
job
i don't add love or knowledge or
inspiration to the world but fuel
further division
because of the guest i have on but
because of my
failure to catalyze
and like steer an inspiring conversation
i see my skill in is not
i mean i don't know how to put it nicely
but not very good
i'm striving to improve constantly so
some of the guest selection has to do
with
the difficulty of the conversation
and how prepared i am for that level of
difficulty
i think the way i think about difficult
conversations
is uh some of them might take years to
prepare for
just intellectually there's there's
certain people and certain spaces of
ideas
that takes a lot of time you have to
remember that
i'm just uh an engineer
i have a set of things that preoccupied
my mind for years
and there's a lot of difficult topics
that
i just won't do a good job of so part of
is i have to work hard to learn more
to kind of constantly look outside the
overton
window to try to explore difficult ideas
and at the same time build enough sort
of
reputation driven freedom to take risks
and make mistakes
or try to inspire people in the
community to allow me to allow each
other
all of us to make mistakes in
conversation so it's the
coupling of extreme thorough preparation
and allowing yourself to make mistakes
it's like
excellence and not giving a damn
combined but overall the thing i'm
concerned about
and i take back the fear i'm not afraid
of it i'm just concerned of doing a bad
job of conversation
i'm not concerned of being cancelled or
derided
or criticized after having done
a reasonably good job i'm concerned
i'm myself it doesn't matter if i'm
cancer or not just when i look in the
mirror
when i look at the results of the
conversation being
a failure something that doesn't add
love to the world but something that has
uh derision and also this is the problem
with words i don't even like how i'm
expressing myself currently
i really try not to have some kind of
agenda
or strategy going into a conversation i
really want to be
fragile open-minded almost boring and
naive
and just giving my trust to a person
even when i challenge or play devil's
advocate all those kinds of things
i really want to place trust
in the mutual respect and the love
that the other person gives and
i trust that they won't take advantage
of that and so
some of the guest selection has to do
with
do i have enough trust yet that this
person
won't take advantage of my
open-mindedness of my
childlike curiosity all those kinds of
things so
but all of this is just a giant learning
experience
i do want to be careful not to let my
curiosity run
what should i say too far ahead of me
where my preparation
doesn't meet the level of curiosity i
exhibit
so again like i said i'm willing
and i'm trying to be more and more
willing to take risks and make mistakes
in conversations
but i'm also not letting myself off the
hook in terms of the level of
preparation
i put and i really hope that we give
each other
the freedom and are patient with each
other
in nuanced conversation that's what
seems to be really missing
in public discourse is this kind of
patience and allowing each other to make
statements that we later change our mind
on
and not putting that statement on us is
this kind of
scarlet letter that forever
puts us in a bin of red or blue
or some other bin so i'm trying to
navigate all of this
while still being naive and open-minded
as best i can
you